[Music]
what does it feel like to be back in st
louis for the u.s chess championships yo
i'm really happy to be back you know i
haven't played a tournament in a year
and a half actually my last tournament
was in st louis at the karen's cup 2020.
so i'm really happy to be back here i
mean this place is like it's like home
for me i've been coming here for more
than a decade now it feels so great
especially after such a long break like
two and a half years and this is part of
my life saint louis coming here for the
u.s championship since year
2009 right yeah
so this is really feel awesome
i'm just glad to be back to
in-person chess and coming back here
because
i played in the 2020 online us women's
which was also really fun in its own way
but uh i do prefer classical and
overboard chess like in person so i'm
glad to be back
it's great to be back i haven't been
here since last time in 2019 i really
love playing here and i really love the
atmosphere especially the chess club um
it's really exciting to play my first us
championship
i've dreamed of playing this tournament
for a really long time so it's cool to
finally be here i have been in college
the past month or two so
it's a nice break to
get off of my dorm and
enjoy saint louis more it feels great
i'm super happy to be back here
and play over the board it's been such a
long time it just feels like an eternity
you know since we played over the board
and i always love the atmosphere here in
san luis it's very exciting it's been a
really long time
not just because of the pandemic but i'm
played in three and a half years so i'm
super excited to be here
it feels nice it feels nice to play over
the board again i didn't really enjoy
any of this online tournament so i'm
really looking forward to it it feels
amazing actually i like and the club and
i like the environment here so
i'm very excited and it's my first time
so
i hope it's going to be
good for me
it feels amazing i'm really happy to be
here and so excited to play the
tournament it's great to be back in
saint louis i look forward to be playing
this tournament after a really long time
many years having a break
and i'm just excited to be back in chess
back in the chess world and to see
people you know
[Music]